we went through this whole thing at
La Chorrera
and left at the end of March
and the woman I was with and I stayed in
Colombia
another month, everybody else went back
and we wrestled with it another month
and I was quite out of it, I think
I believed that she would give birth to the Word itself
and I believed that it would be a little glass fiancé bead
that I had lost in Laos five years earlier
and when she began to develop a round sore on the top of her mouth
it was exactly the size of this thing
then I realized that this little object
would drop down onto her tongue someday soon
and she would deliver it to me, and
that it would be the Word made flesh
it would be the..
now are you alarmed?!
now do you begin to get the
drift
that we've attempted suppress along?
I was flaming
and it took me years and years
to dial it down
so that it's even as friendly and packageable
as it is in the present moment
because for a long time it wasn't, I mean it just drove people to the walls
I mean they just said "I don't know"and "I don't want to hear any.."
and "I've had it" and "call me when you're better", you know...